O'Brien's to do that I used to [ __ ]
do that I would I feel it bullying when
I was a kid especially when you were the
kid when you guys were playing with
rocks and sticks when when when I was a
kid [ __ ]
well you're being a serious age when I
was a kid though it's like they've they
roast you on your shoes or like if you
had a busted face so I'm like that but
it wasn't relentless and then once you
stucked up for yourself like fought it
was over I never got bullied but I did
have mmm but a bunch of my friends who
were football players they got no they
they did a friend my friends was a
little heavy she was heavy if a friend
yep and I found out that they were
making fun of her she went off crying
and Albright why were they making fun of
her though because she was fat and just
because she was fat I see what you don't
want us to get old bride who's the nice
guy you don't want to get me you don't
start that key no because I'll fight
everybody want to rev up this old old
duels O's 'mobile because you want to
revel the skinny monk and we'll take out
some eyes and [ __ ] some people up I
don't Calif you are I get right yeah the
boys off when I feel righteous I come at
you and I went out at that table and I
said I said now I'm gonna [ __ ] now I
said I'm how I said you know I know
you're lying Pro I said who wants to die
yeah these entire table football players
don't believe your story the entire
table went your right bride my bad
yep no one's not they came out beautiful
I went and I [ __ ] kicked them in
their faces
yeah I gave him an I gave gave each one
I'm a facecam yep no ice not hear you
but did that yeah there should be iced I
just can't
it's so strange to me kids even put up
when you're getting ready for your
special Joe did you you didn't feel sets
like at the store or the Laugh Factory
or them no no I went to weird places
yeah yeah I went to coffee houses then
what - I just wanted to work out stuff
yeah uh and wait you're talking about
what I did Corbin when I when I did like
my TV set that's when I I wanted four
minutes set yeah because I didn't do a
TV sitting a while and uh I wondered
they're hard four minutes is hard and I
wanted to put myself in weird spots
yeah so I was I was going around like
Lankershim there was like a weed house
that was doing stand-up I was going like
like the front you know the improv the
my something like environments were like
I didn't have my audience you know where
I love those I love those environment I
just did a about hair salon last night
perfect literally an alleyway and I went
is this the cake and it was I walk in
its an old hair salon basically a room
and the modeling could be it's in Culver
City and I walk up on stage and I'm
surrounded by there people sitting on
either side of me so I'm surrounded by
people it's like theater-in-the-round or
something getting perfectly shitty
curtain in front of me it was so much
fun it was what it was it brings me back
to New York that's those the kind of
gigs I did yeah I did 1000 of those gigs
yeah you did wherever you could any when
you get up on these in these coffee shop
people are talking back there bars Dov
Davidoff and I did a show on time he
goes come come open for me I go all
right heads in downtown LA it was in it
was for some Jewish God why charity
trying to be racist right now but why is
it always the Jewish charity thing we
all have a Jewish charity story I really
do
mine was with uh God what's his name uh
a buddy Buddy Hackett son oh my god oh
my god oh sandy Hackett no but I know
Buddy Hackett son Danny a cadiz he was a
comic in in Vegas and my worst gig that
I tell everybody is the charity I did
for sandy Hackett was in this restaurant
it was I think it was a deli and then uh
the stage was literally an eight-person
seat booth yeah they put plywood on it
because you know those eight seat person
booths around yeah they put plywood on
top it that was a stage oh yeah and then
they put like this karaoke microphone
and by the way when I see karaoke this
is like 92 93 or whatever so we're
talking to take Cosette I'll do you one
better okie machine rifle I don't know
15 20 it was a restaurant oh yeah it's a
John payment you know how he paid me he
he didn't pay me cash she goes they uh
the charity is uh three hundred dollars
a plate and you and your girl can eat
for free so I mean if you think about it
it's like 600 bucks
sandy I'm so dumb and I sit there and I
go where are we gonna perform and they
had a speaker like an amp and they did
that you plug in I go yeah and there was
a Myka
well but the problem is that there's no
stage so I'm I'm level with these people
and they're all here so so this is it so
I go what are we gonna do and it was low
ceilings and by the way it was up in a
room and the bar was downstairs
so you could hero buddy downstairs so I
said they're not gonna hear us and this
is not possible
so I see a couch that is four dogs it's
a little mini I'm not kidding on a mini
leather couch for dogs and don't ask me
what I was doing in this upstairs [ __ ]
room so I go let me see if this works
and I pulled this little cat side go up
and pick up the couch and I walk it over
and I stand on it and I go I guess
this'll have to do
so I take the mic and I open for dove
and I do 15 20 minutes they all are
lying down sitting down there no chairs
and standing and we do stand up to their
credit they listened they [ __ ] listen
do they laugh and they laughed and then
dove got up and did 45 minutes on that
[ __ ] ridiculous couch on a dog couch
holding rushed well then you couldn't so
the ceiling was about six inches above
my head did you guys get paid did not
get paid I did it as a favor to Dov he
got money cause you say that he get paid
yeah I don't know I can't repel to slap
your stupid face okay that's good
I like that and I can tell by your wig
that's good too I it's making me mad but
it's good okay you can use it okay and I
can also look at you and just go you're
very compelling oh thanks man now that
as a straight man you want to talk
straight man I can't really say that to
you but you could because if I if I look
like but it's suggestive if I go I have
to be honest with you you're very
compelling I mean it's a really great
cop it's a way of saying you're
interesting right yeah like very
interested to a girl though
I'd be well-read you say that the
Instagram mouse what the [ __ ] correct
that's what I mean it's a sophisticated
word you're compelling and even more so
without your pants mm-hmm I like that I
mean but you couldn't say your [ __ ] is
compelling you could say it wouldn't be
what would be a good word because when
you say your [ __ ] is compelling it's
fine but I want something even stronger
like [ __ ] is perfect that's always
that's nice it's simple but it's good
it's perfect not too big not too small
hmm okay Ellen this is a compelling
story yeah or this you a lot of times
it's just this you got a dick on you
well I told you to Leah loves being
around me at the Comedy Store when dudes
come up to me and those lines they give
me like dude dude you like steak I'm in
the middle of conversation with Julie I
go excuse me is like steak hell yeah I
guess so man I like steak yes let's go
get a steak sometime all right
absolutely not
thank you though no thank you no thank
you let's go hang let's get a shake man
like smoothies well my when you get to
be a little bit more known and then you
come into town and your mother or
someone says hey I want you to have
dinner with these distant relatives or
your people from high school go let's
come out on my boat III that's always
confusing cuz I don't really wanna cuz I
don't really who wanna know I can't get
doing that since day one white yeah yeah
yeah you look rich at first a little
hood rich yep I'm just getting over that
yeah yeah spend it before I had it you
know Nordstrom Rack are you not good my
head Neiman Marcus Lisa always spent
more than you always always did I'm the
same way I'm the worst when I wasn't
when I was uh when I was coming up I'd
work at Nordstrom Rack and I worked at
Borders Books and literally spend my
paychecks on a Gucci [ __ ] at Nordstrom's
rack oh yeah there's pictures of me like
like in a newspaper I got a picture if
we're in a Gucci bucket head and I
remember like spending my whole paycheck
I made it Mirage I was working at the
Mirage just for that backpack Gucci
bucket hat you know it's interesting how
you know it's like Gucci like it's it's
like the hottest thing around the
hottest brand it's like it's crossed
over in there like pop culture and rap
mmm now Gucci and love those brands have
come out like anti like urban like
they've been stuff and they don't want
them that the products really not for
the urban lower class Society they don't
want them heaven we were just yesterday
I love that you're saying that it's kind
of like they don't like rappers with the
name Gucci Mane they hate it they don't
want they think it even though they have
literally brought their sales up through
the roof did you know they did so it's
like all these fashion houses like
there's a main fashion house that owns
like Gucci YSL all all under the same
banner yeah there's what I'm swayed into
fashion so there's one like house and
there's all these brands that branch off
of it so the mess with the pricing
releases of all the things but everyone
they're making the same they're making
the same makeup they don't make money
off their shoes and clothes for the
actually it's a loss for them they make
money off their perfumes and everything
bag yeah the cheap [ __ ] you have the
true beauty yeah there's just like a
side hustle yeah I could see that
because the shoes are yeah these are
nothing as far as profit but that bag is
[ __ ] [ __ ]